alles klar es
geht nicht lauter
wir machen heute ein stück torte denn
mein zwei rega neffe und ich haben das
gemeinsam belieben weichen spongebob
schwammkopf aber gab es wäre wenn ich
nicht von sport betreibt mir ist die
kommentare wenn wir mindestens eine
folge mal gesehen habt oder auch so
wichtig sei so sehe ich habe so ein
bisschen was vorbereitet weil das wird
halt so eine motiv torte ich habe ich
hier meine biscuit böden dafür gibt es
einen basic selbst gemacht für solche
videos habe ich dieses basic rezept
gemacht damit ihr einfach darauf
zugreifen können ich habe jetzt zweimal
20er böden ich werde euch in die infobox
schreiben welche menge ich genommen habe
und wie lange sie bei mir gebacken haben
und sich auch vorbereitet habe ist meine
suisse mehring buttercreme die finde ich
super lecker da habe ich mit lemon
gehört aromatisiert das jetzt gibt's
auch schon auf dem kanal als unten in
der video beschreibung und was ich jetzt
mache ist noch eine sahne quark und
dafür nehme ich mir die küchenmaschine
gibt da same rhein zusammen mit vanille
extrakt zucker und sahne fest und wer
das einmal komplett steif schlagen
so steif geschlagene sahne kommt jetzt
auch unseren magerquark und dann
vorsichtig verrühren mit einem
schneebesen und dann zeige ich euch wie
wir die torte stapeln
[Musik]
so zum schichten habe ich jetzt einen
boden auf mein kickboard gelegt meint
exel tortenring drum herum ja die torte
ist ein bisschen höher man sieht auch
dadurch dass die jetzt fast bis zum rand
ist ist sie ungefähr vierzehneinhalb
zentimeter hoch ich habe übrigens auch
butter kleben am äußeren rand
aufgespritzt damit ich quasi die fondant
deko vor der sahne creme schütze denn
fondant löst sich mit sahne auf ich habe
noch frische himbeeren dazu gegeben und
jetzt gebe ich noch so ein bisschen
buttercreme auf die oberfläche streicht
das schön glatt damit die oberfläche
auch nicht auch jetzt noch sahne dran
damit die oberfläche jetzt auch nicht
austrocknet denn die torte kommt jetzt
zum kühlen für 20 minuten in den
kühlschrank
[Musik]
meine mutter kam habe ich jetzt noch ein
gefährt ich möchte nämlich gern so einen
schönen farbverlauf die torte konnte
ziemlich durch kühlen das heißt wenn er
anfasst dann bleibt nichts an den
fingern kleben und so ist es genau
richtig ein teil von der buttercreme
allerdings noch weiß lassen das brauchen
wir nämlich gleich für die deko und
jetzt nehme ich mir jeweils eine farbe
ich habe hell mittel und dunkelblau
genommen wobei das helles er sein sohn
mintgrün aber ich nicht dass auch schick
und jetzt einmal einfüllen solche
spritzbeutel und wollen die spitze
abschneiden und dann zeige ich euch wie
ich das ganze auf die torte spritze und
klatscht reich
[Musik]
und wenn ihr dann den rand mit meiner
hohen teil karte abzieht dann entsteht
so ein schönes ambri muster und um habe
ich nur noch unregelmäßig glatt
gestrichen und das was hier oben ist
dieser überschuss bei anderen torten
zieht den immer noch glatt aber ich
finde ich hier sie das mit der optik
ganz cool aus deshalb lasse ich das
jetzt einfach so ich werde dort jetzt
nochmal kühlen und euch zeige ich ihnen
inzwischen zeit wie ihr es von tieren
können viel spaß damit
[Musik]
ich habe meine torte ist nach der kunst
hat einmal auf die tortenplatte gelegen
ich finde dieses blaue passt doch noch
mal so richtig gut jetzt geht's an die
deko ich habe mir viel vorgenommen ich
möchte einmal das anderen das haus
machen dafür habe ich hier orange
eingefärbten fondant dann wollte ich
gern noch eigen machen und eventuell
noch quallen bontrup marke so gern
quallen zwischen ich würde sagen ich
mache jetzt einfach mal und ihr schaut
euch das ganze an weil ich finde nichts
kann man besser erklären als es einfach
zu zeigen
[Musik]
so unsere ananas klebt da braucht er
kein extra kleber funktioniert ganz gut
mit der buttercreme und ich habe auch
schon hier die blätter und drüber
gemacht das werde ich jetzt ein wenig
aushärten lassen das funktioniert
einfach eine luftig gibt es aber in den
kühlschrank damit ein bisschen schneller
geht und dann wird es einfach nur noch
so darüber gegeben
[Musik]
thür könnt ihr auch ganz einfach blauen
fondant nehmen und die einzelnen teile
ausschneiden ich muss sagen es ist total
easy weil die tür ist halt wirklich
einfach nur einen bogen und dann haben
wir noch zwei fenster und den
schornstein es ist wirklich
selbsterklärend und daher habe ich auch
schon direkt weiter gemacht mit den
quallen denn auch gab auch die keine
vorlage einfach aus rosen fondant
ausschneiden die flossen noch mal so ein
bisschen form indem ihr den von dazu
eine wurst form und die haben auch nur
so typische violette pünktchen ich mache
jetzt noch die algen die gehen auch
superschnelle eigentlich ist auch eine
anfänger geeignet orte wenn ihr halt in
spongebob nicht macht weil ich muss
sagen der ist schon ein bisschen
schwieriger
[Musik]
und dann ist die torte ich hoffe das ist
das rezept gefallen hat und ihr könnt
mir jetzt noch um in die kommentare
schreiben welcher lieblingscharakter von
spongebob ist ich muss es sein mein
lieblingscharakter ist plankton ich mag
den echt gerne was ich mag natürlich den
fronten liebsten in süßes pony und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß um
nachmachen und schreibt mir gerne
feedback hier unten in die kommentare
und ansonsten sehen wir uns auch beim
nächsten rezept cherokee
[Musik]